أنا الدكتور مات جيلبرت من النرويج في
مهمة طبية طارئة إلى غزة في
انتظار السماح لي بالدخول عبر رافا في
القاهرة في تمام الساعة الخامسة وخمس دقائق بتوقيت جرينتش بعد ظهر
اليوم، قافلة كانت
ستنقل المرضى المصابين في
سيارات إسعاف ذات علامات جيدة من مستشفى الشفاء إلى
رفح جنوب غزة تعرضت لهجوم
من قبل قوات الاحتلال الإسرائيلي أثناء
خروجهم من أبواب الشفاء تم
قصفهم أه مسعف واحد وأصيب سائق
المسعف إصابة خطيرة
قررت القافلة الرجوع للعودة
إلى الشفاء وبمجرد وصولها  على
أبواب الشفاء تم قصفهم مرة أخرى أه
العدد الأخير هو 13 قتيل و 62 جريح
هذه القافلة كانت قافلة مخطط لها
مع مرضى جرحى كانوا
سينقلون تم إبلاغ اللجنة الدولية للصليب الأحمر
حسب معلوماتي كانوا
يتوقعون أه  مرافقة
اللجنة الدولية للصليب الأحمر التي لم تصل،
فغادروا المستشفى وتعرضوا كما قلت
للهجوم مرتين، وهذا
انتهاك صارخ للقانون الدولي، وهو
مثال آخر على التجاهل التام من جانب
الجيش الإسرائيلي
لقواعد القانون العامة التي تلتزم بها.  ينبغي حماية
المدنيين، ويجب حماية سيارات الإسعاف المميزة
التي حصلت على معلومات عنها،
وهناك
شيء آخر مهم كان القادة العسكريون الإسرائيليون
يهددون بالاتصال به خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين وهو
حث
قادة المستشفيات في جميع
المستشفيات في شمال جاسا  لإفراغ
المستشفى من المرضى والموظفين لأنهم
كانوا في طريقهم لتفجير قيادة المستشفى والأطباء والممرضين
والممرضين في المستشفى وقد رفضوا
القيام بذلك لأنهم كانوا
خائفين على أمن وسلامة
مرضاهم الآن عندما يبدأون في
الإخلاء  ويقومون بالتنسيق،
وهذه سيارات إسعاف عامة تحمل
علامات دولية لسيارات الإسعاف.
ما الذي يحدث أنهم يتعرضون للقصف من قبل
الجيش الإسرائيلي ليس مرة واحدة بل مرتين وهم في
طريقهم للخروج إلى ما قال الإسرائيليون
إنه ملاذ آمن في جنوب غزة،
هذا هو  عديم الرحمة ووحشي للغاية لدرجة أنني
أود أن أسأل وزير الخارجية بلينكين
الموجود الآن في إسرائيل، لقد كنت تقوم
بهذه الهجمات على
المدنيين منذ أسابيع حتى الآن، أين هو
الخط الأحمر، هل هناك أي خط أحمر
لمقتل المدنيين والأطفال البالغين
والمرضى والعاملين في مجال الصحة؟  قصف
المستشفيات حتى الآن وصلنا إلى أكثر
من 9000 قتيل على الأقل 4000 منهم من
الأطفال والآن أه أنتم تشاهدون
الجيش الإسرائيلي يقصف قافلة من السفارة
هذه مسؤولية
الحكومة الأمريكية الرئيس جو بايدن والسيد
بلينكن لقد سمحتم أن يحدث هذا
ليس لديك دماء على يديك، أنت
غارقة في
الدم